[Music]
is it true that you have a brother that
works here at Warner Brothers is that
yes yeah yeah yeah my brother Terry does
he hit you brother Terry he was the key
grip on the Gilmore Girls and he worked
her a long time ago he doesn't work on
that show anymore
but he lives on the lot he lives on the
lot
he's a lot squatter you brother brother
that worked on Gilmore Girls
yeah Gilmore Girls shuts down a while
ago had an issue slash the show shut
down because of him I think haha and you
now lives on a lot I think you've got
some security footage of them we have
security that you brought I think you
brought security footage of your brother
who just squats here on the Warner
Brothers lot let's take a look this
area's this block this region I am
running low on supplies get off my
street plays this is my strength don't
worry it's just
I can take a piss in the middle of the
street if I want to because it's by take
a crap right now and guess what I feel
like it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you should see if he's okay did reach
out to her here you might as well we're